so we've had a really amazing set of
sessions earlier today talking about the
signs of smart cities that Jim just
moderated we had remarks from our
sponsors
we had Raj talk about the vision for for
Metro 21 this is really to my mind
perhaps one of the most important
sessions in our in our event today we
just do with how are we going to pay for
having these smart city deployments
actually be made how are we actually
going to make it happen
not just the financial model but or what
are the various means by which you're
going to make it happen and and as we as
you heard in the in the deans panel we
talked about the fact that we have is
amazing testbed here in Pittsburgh and
Allegheny County we talked about this
partnership between the city the county
the public sector the private sector the
foundations and the university to do
piloting in demonstration the RD&D
approach what we want to talk about
today with a really esteemed group of
panelists that I'll introduce in just a
minute
is really to sort of ask the question
how might we think about public-private
partnerships as a particular mechanism
to realize some of the the benefits and
opportunities that these technologies
present to us so the panelists that I
have here let me give a one-sentence
introduction and have them then speak
about this question from their point of
view Lee Haller director of innovation
and performance city of Pittsburgh a
little round of applause
[Applause]
Catherine Egon Kellerman who joined us
was on the other end chief
Allegheny County for Thor ditch CEO
Richard viz presidency of Duquesne Light
Frank Bascom bottie director business
development from Bosch and Jim young CEO
of chief operating officer of crown
castle
so with this context setting that I did
I'm gonna turn this over to the
panelists and we'll go pretty much in
the order of introduction though they
aren't quite seated in that order we
bump it bounce around so if none is over
to lead to kick things off leave first
of all thank you very much for having me
what I thought I would do is start out
by talking a little bit about the
Department of innovation performance to
provide some context for you know kind
of where I'm coming from in some of my
comments on the panel today so the
Department of innovation and performance
with the city is four years old and
we've recently went through a strategic
planning effort as a department to
really hone what it is that our
department should be focused on doing
and our mission as a department is to
elevate the work of city government so
we are not a department that's out
fighting fires plowing streets filling
potholes inspecting buildings doing any
of those services but we're the
department with the technology
professionals and other professionals
that should be helping to improve those
services so whether it's introducing new
technologies to make those services more
efficient and more effective we also
have a portion of our our staff that is
focused on engagement so social media
web cable and print talking about all of
the good things that the employees of
the city of Pittsburgh are doing so
that's kind of where we're we're coming
from in terms of the mission of the
organization as part of our strategic
planning effort
one of the other things just to keep in
mind is that we feel like one of the
core roles that we can play as a
department is to be technical stewards
for the city of Pittsburgh so
historically we have 19 different
departments in the city of Pittsburgh
historically there hasn't really been a
very strong governance model around
technology investments across those 19
different departments and as a result we
have a fairly substantial amount of
technical debt we've made big
investments in systems that were scoped
out by one of those 19 departments and
not really considering the needs of
other departments so you know it's a
it's a challenge for us to kind of work
our way out of that technical debt but I
come to the topic of smart city
implementations from that that
standpoint that we have to be very
cautious about the investments that we
make as a city because clearly our
motivations are protecting taxpayer
dollars and making sure the the
investments that we make have the
maximum benefit for the citizens of
Pittsburgh I think that there's
definitely room for partnerships with
University and with private sector we
love working with with metro 21 but I
think the challenge from the city
standpoint is that we really need to
start with the business need and work
our way back to what technology is best
to meet that very specific business need
the smart city space and kind of the way
that the city city politics works
sometimes the smart city things are the
sexy you know flashy things that
everybody wants to talk about and so we
go all-in on investments on those things
but we really haven't thought that at
the heart of it what is the business
challenge that we're trying to meet so
that's that's what we're trying to do as
a department and I can provide some
examples of how we're trying to do that
in in future comments
good afternoon and again thank you for
having us thank you for the invitation
um who and here has taken transit in
Pittsburgh in the last month so that's
why I have a job thank you thanks very
much I am wrapping up week number seven
as the CEO so at the Port Authority so I
will be less helpful on the conversation
of what the Port Authority has done and
more helpful in the conversation of
where I was previously it was tamp it's
a small city but we did broadly
paraphrase Shakespeare we were small but
we were fierce you have to try harder
when you have no money and no resources
transit in its best use is something you
don't notice it removes friction it good
afternoon
Carly it makes your life happen it makes
all the points come together in three
years my goal is we're not saying about
Port Authority or what's going on it's
Port Authority was a great partner at a
community event or moving forward I
image to a very cool MWBE training
program because a transportation portion
is so seamless nearly a quarter million
people a day take transit here in
Pittsburgh I'm wearing boots I started
off my morning at the incline who has
taken the incline so I was digging
around you know there's two sets of
breaks that was very reassuring since
I've taken my children on it but you
know we range from the incline to the
tee and where can that go the old
trolley system and then buses there's
all sorts of cool new stuff coming down
which I'm hopeful I'll hear about
especially from Posche we don't need to
try to compete with that and we wouldn't
be good at it we need to focus on what
we do well and leave the door open to be
supportive almost as an equity partner
in a lot of our smart cities and
emerging technology so how can we help
it come together and how can we get out
of the way because honestly doing our
governmental equity thing is sort of the
opposite like the Venn diagram of being
creative in government that's us
so how can we connect this really big
base of passengers and become the most
attractive place for anybody in the
country especially here in Pittsburgh if
you're doing something new with
transportation you
should never have to leave to give it a
test drive so that's the nutshell and
again thank you for having me today
Thank You Katherine Richard thank you
well thank you all for having me here as
well you know as we as we think about
smart cities and public-private
partnerships you know to what Leah said
a little bit earlier we kind of approach
it from what's the problem we're trying
to solve and then put the teams together
to figure out what the solution is so
setting that aside you know as we think
about smart cities and how that may play
into a public-private partnership it's
what the each of the parties bring to
the table and when we think about smart
cities you know we think about what are
the three pillars that kind of underpin
what's going to be required to make that
successful you know the first pillar we
think about it's got to cost-effectively
gather all the data that's out there so
that's infrastructure intensive and
that's a lot of devices that have to go
in the field the second thing that we
think about is you got to deliver the
data to the cloud so what's the
communication backbone and
infrastructure it's only get it up to
the cloud then the third pillar we think
about is the application development
who's going to develop the apps how are
they going to have access to that data
how are they going to turn that into
meaningful information that could really
you know add value at the end of the day
so when we think about it you know
things that we do is a utility that we
think we do well is we build and operate
networks we have a lot of assets in a
field now we have polls that can be used
for various devices depending on the
nature of the municipality the city of
Pittsburgh owns their own streetlights
but we own the streetlights and all of
the other municipalities are out there
so we have those assets that are into
the field we have a lot of Technology
across our system we're really good at
operating the SCADA system that we have
with thousands of devices that are
measuring in real time the flow of
electrical energy and then switching you
know switching schemes to you know run
this system very reliably and very safe
and then we have the communication
backbone that goes across that as well
that takes all that data back you know
to our control rooms and to where we
apply logic to it we're deemed a
critical infrastructure company so other
things you think about is the security
of the data so you know we have really
perfected a lot of practices internally
to keep the system secure
or cyber secure so to speak so I think
as we think about public partnerships
there'll be a lot of us sitting here at
the table they bring different assets of
the table I think we have to think about
how do we not replicate what's in the
field how do we take advantage of
existing assets that are there in such a
way that we can leverage them you know
to make this become a more of a
sustainable reality thank you Richard
Frank good afternoon and thank you again
for allowing me the opportunity to be
here to represent Bosh we're very
excited to speak on the topic of smart
cities how many people in the audience
have a Bosch appliance very nice how
many have bosch power tools well better
yet how many have an electronic
stability control in their car oh this
is impressive all right the last one how
many have a industrial size let's say
hydraulics in their home hi I got you so
what I'm trying to say is that we have a
broad I say spectrum of products and
solutions that we can offer to the
market we don't not only can bring the
hardware we can bring the software we
have for business sectors and those what
I just mentioned to you in in the in the
test to draw from we see smart cities as
an opportunity to work at a level where
we've not been involved in so for us
Marc cities is a new endeavor I've been
in this role for about a year we've been
doing smart cities for about six years
on a global basis even though we're a
ninety seven billion dollar company 130
years young this is a new space for us
so we're very excited we do see the
public-private partnerships as one of
the key avenues to actually deploy some
of the technologies we can bring to the
market we see other avenues of ways to
do that I'll discuss that a little bit
later in my comments but where I just
want to talk about we are active in 14
different what we call beacon projects
around the world a couple of them are
local in fact we did quote the RFP for
the networks of LED lights for the city
of Pittsburgh we're excited about that
and we're also working with other cities
in the US and in Canada to try and bring
some of these solutions so we do see
there's a lot of energy around the topic
we do see there's also some impediments
having to do with
funding I think there was a lot of good
discussions this morning about how maybe
certain ways of funding these projects
can be taken on but I think from our
perspective you know we're a technology
solutions provider we have what we call
our slogan were invented for life but
ultimately what we're striving for is
quality of life for citizens in
communities and cities that we do
projects in thank you Frank
Jim great just to say how many people
have any idea who crown Castle is oh wow
that's awesome was that from earlier
presentation perhaps Chris great so you
know that we're about shared
telecommunications infrastructure that's
what we do the second pillar that
mystery Ozzy talked about is exactly
where we are and we have a really strong
belief that the best infrastructure to
deploy is that infrastructure that can
be shared that is the most effective
economic use of that infrastructure and
and we believe that that will be very
prominent as we move forward in a smart
city environment we've done a number of
projects with cities around the country
in deploying different aspects of smart
city and providing that connective
tissue that really powers a lot of the
infrastructure we're not the cameras
we're not the software it's very similar
to what Richard talked about is it's the
stuff that you don't see I guarantee you
everybody that checked their cell phone
today ran over a lot of crown castle
infrastructure and probably some of
Richard's infrastructure at least charge
your phone with his nothing else today
right so we have been exposed to a lot
of different funding approaches to these
kinds of projects I think what's
important I think we all realize this is
they have that the models have to be
adaptive there is not one model for
Pittsburgh that will be the exact same
model for Tampa it's got to be adapted
to the situation the priorities of the
location of the jurisdiction in the city
that that's exploring those things and
we absolutely believe that those that
connective tissue and that
infrastructure of which there is not
enough I can promise you that however
much we have today and we have a lot in
Pittsburgh we have a lot of
infrastructure in Pittsburgh - and I'm
not just talking crown that our
community has a lot of infrastructure
but some of the the demands for data
transport that come
things like autonomous vehicles the
latency requirements that such
undoubtably talked about in his
presentation that requires a lot of
infrastructure and it is no small
investment it's a significant investment
but it's one that I think best made in
partnership with an eye towards all the
uses and the best ways to to deploy that
infrastructure so it can be used by a
variety of interest parties both public
and private I think has the best
opportunity and the best way forward for
us as we embark on this project thank
you Jim
first thing is I want to thank each and
every one of you for the partnership
with Metro 21 we have the public sector
technology solution providers and
infrastructure providers the second is
an observation you know when we had the
Dean's here Karen had to flash this
thing about you know please conclude
you're running out of time none of that
I mean they all came in on time or
underneath time and so here you can you
can tell these folks are about you know
being able to make their points and
effectively so which which now you know
no pressure so now I want to sort of
seed of the discussion with a few
questions and then sort of open it up
for for discussion before we get to the
you know some of you talked about
particular examples of deployments and
other things you've done with creative
and adaptive models of public-private
partnerships but if you take if you take
a step back and ask the question how
might we use your infrastructure the
technologies to really meet the real
needs of citizens to improve their
quality of life to maximize the benefits
if you will of what it is the your firms
and your technology solution providers
are bringing to there how might we go
about doing that and from your
experience from each of your different
perspectives from the public sector or
the private sector what do you see as a
big constraint that needs to be overcome
go ahead want me to start first sure
so as we look at our infrastructure in
the field as I indicated a little bit
earlier you know we we do have the polls
that are out there we do have the
streetlights that are out there that
sensing equipment can be mounted on when
you look at the regulatory model that we
have currently
it really doesn't lend itself to that
you know there would have to be some
regulatory changes you know that we
would have to implement at the PUC which
regulates us that gets us more into
instead of this cost the service notion
where you get a return on your equity
where it could be more market-based
pricing where we could sit out there and
say you know we have an asset we can
leverage it we can put additional
devices on there and we can sell the
data as a service or have access to it
for some fee of some sort I mean we
haven't actually sat down and thought
that through you know like any other
publicly how a privately held company
our investors expect to return so when
you look at the regulatory model when
you start to venture into areas that
generate additional revenue when you go
in for your base business they use that
as a revenue offset what which you would
be requiring with the rate increase
which theoretically major taking on more
operational risk and you get no reward
for that operational risk so the model
has to change to attract the capital
from our investor base to be able to
leverage infrastructure that we have
already in the field I think from the
city standpoint we're obviously a fairly
infrastructure rich in that we own in
most cases all of the the traffic poles
at every intersection in the city
thousands and thousands of not
necessarily all the telephone poles
where our street lights are mounted but
we have many decorative light poles that
we own we have public buildings that we
own all over the city so we have a lot
of infrastructure that's well spread out
across the city that could be leveraged
for four implementations like this I
mean our smart PGH application to the US
Department of Transportation envisioned
taking advantage of that in certain
smart corridors I think the challenge
for us is in kind of our interest is
making sure that the data backhaul is is
there and it's something that is
open and can be built on for future
applications so as our streetlight you
know implementation as an example we're
making we're trying to make sure that as
part of that process
we're opening the door for future
implementations and providing an
infrastructure that will provide the
data backhaul for future smart city
implementations and not just considering
this one particular use case around the
the streetlight conversion so that's
that's kind of been a challenge for us
is figuring out the right way to go
forward with that I can talk a little
bit about where we're coming from as a
technology provider about some of the
sensors for example videos so there was
a lot of talk today about what video can
do I mean it's not just a video I think
really it's the edge computing that was
talked about even the cloud computing
but I think it's really the analytics
that you can derive in the data that you
can derive from sensors like video
cameras and I'm not talking the video
itself it's what we would call the
metadata so I think it was described as
little pixels and those devices but
things like counting people you know we
can do traffic counting we can also do a
lot of different things but what we
would provide as the technology
solutions provider is the the data
source so our sensors that would be put
up on whether its utility poles or its
street lights can provide the data input
and a lot of these sensors to be quite
honest have come from our mobility
sector and that is our largest business
sector within the Boche group a lot of
these sensors are very robust they've
been developed for extreme environments
but they're also very cost effective
because the the base micro sensors that
go into them are built in volumes of
millions in some cases tens of millions
so where we see we can offer for a more
cost-effective solution again is taking
advantage of the existing infrastructure
adding these additional sensors but it's
really deriving the data that other
policies and planning decisions could be
made so in the past years one of the big
topics in transportation is why can't
you do more business with uber and lyft
and and they have an excellent
application and we can't we shouldn't
compete with that because they just do
it better but it's been very challenging
for entities that do partner with them
to get data back
because you know from my perspective
their value is in the data that they're
collecting like there's not a thing
about me that lyft doesn't know and and
that's that's got a lot of value
especially if it follows me past the end
of my location so of course that's their
money they don't want to share it but as
a public entity I need to know where
those trips are beginning and ending so
our challenge many times has been
leaving our platform open so we can
facilitate some service or it's some
interchange back and forth but we need
to know exactly how that's being used so
I think there's a recurrent theme as
maybe we're swimming in data and finding
that which is useful in winnowing and on
that maybe that's a common challenge Jim
did you ever so so I talked earlier and
bandwidth is hugely talked about that
having the right bandwidth to move all
this data around and we know that
eventually either at data ingest or when
the data is processed back out and used
to actually make a deployment of some
sort whether it's a lift or nuber or a
bus that data is going to travel wide
odourless wirelessly and today it's
really difficult to deploy wireless
broadband and the deployments that are
most important in an urban environment
and even a suburban environment are
small cell deployments and inaccurate
some Richards comments the regulatory
environment is not good does not does
not facilitate that mostly through lack
of policy I'm speaking initially
generically because it applies really to
most jurisdictions around the country
and where we've seen the best success is
working towards a joint regulatory
policy that makes it easy to deploy that
bandwidth so all the infrastructure that
my colleagues up here have mentioned
their buildings
there's poles that's great but if if
especially the private entity that's
deploying that infrastructure can't make
it through rezoning and permitting
process in less than 24 months it
becomes an inhibitor to move all the
data around that we want to do so I
think yeah if I want to do business with
AV and it takes like 4 terabytes of data
exactly and it's clearly not plugged in
anywhere that's right yeah that's right
so so we've we've had discussions with a
lot of partners in Pittsburgh about we
have terabytes of data to move how can
you help us now terabytes is a little
beyond Wireless at this point but it
won't be beyond Wireless
ever and that's where the fiber assets
that we've talked about come into play
so having a part of the partnership is
building a regulatory environment that
is not without regular dilation I'm
certainly not arguing for that at all
but just getting to the point where
because it's about it's highly
transactional and repetitive right and
if we can get a construct in the policy
that enables infrastructure to be ployed
easily and quickly to meet the needs
really driven by the jurisdiction in
this case the city I think that's that's
really a path to success so a great
kickoff to the discussion I mean so
there are two sort of points being made
I think one relates to sort of a
different approach to regulation on the
one hand allowing for the private entity
to be able to recover market prices but
at the same time providing the public
entity with capacity to use it for other
use cases then for the particular use
case and then to Karen's point the
question of who owns the data this came
up in an earlier discussion as well
related to the citizens own the data
does the public entity on the data about
if so then how does the private service
provider monetize their services so
there's an interesting set of tensions
in this and and we're going to have this
solved in 20 minutes but but I just
wanted to sort of in terms of framing
the discussion
are there other quadrants and see the
other questions that the audience has in
this regard about public-private
partnerships either in the context of
the regulatory frameworks that they've
started out the discussion with or in
regard to other points that you'd like
to raise any any questions from the
audience
yep on that side yes sir done
partnerships exchanging data
transparency of data video cameras
sensors all over the place there's
there's the problem that Anthony towns
and calls the basket of remotes problem
which is we all have three or four
remotes at home to
control our TV our DVD player our sound
system and they don't talk to each other
there's always this thing is there a
universal remote that really works so
the same thing happens with exchange of
data with equipment hard you know hard
data soft that or whatever it might be
you talk about how you think that can be
resolved from your points of view as as
really suppliers of many of these
services that we need to do in order to
understand and create a smart city maybe
I could start a little bit the data is
for us as key to I think it's smart city
we've all can agree on that
but from our perspective that the data
can also mean new business models so
from our perspective
whatever sensors we provide data to and
from we believe in open data sources
because we can actually develop and we
have develop solutions that are at base
for example we're looking at ways to
bring together multiple you mentioned
the basket of remotes but if you look at
it from a basket of apps it's the same
problem so you're coming into a city and
you want to use multimodal
transportation and you want it all in
one map our one app excuse me so we've
developed some solutions where we can
bring together pieces from an uber or
pieces from a car to go and make it and
one map one app but not only is it one
app but you can do the process so it's a
multi-modal approach now it's not
perfect but these are we're seeing the
same benefits with data being available
for all of us to come up with you know
better solutions for cities and it
that's us it makes more sense than a
closed data system definitely for
standards back in but 2009 2010 once
Google had cleaned up their maps enough
so they wouldn't tell you for instance
get off a subway and then connect to a
street you couldn't get to we could um
we could push our data out in our GTFS
and all of our data was streamlined and
everyone was using the same format and
so what goes into Google to tell you
what bus to take was the same format
that these app developers could grab and
go and that made life very easy for us
now it's when we have one app that wants
a data formatted this way or I've got it
coming out of my vehicle locators
in a different format it makes my life
so much easier for my IT team just to
scrub it down to one standard and then
beyond that III kid that there's a 12
year old messing around in her parents
basement waiting to write my next app
but I really believe this is the case
and a good example of this in San
Francisco Bay Area Transit Muni just
post all their open-source data and then
they let people build all the apps that
they want which goes into a security
constraint and a security concern of how
open is your system how much money are
you investing in your firewalls and your
cyber security and is it worth it to do
that to leave the data open I'll leave
that up to the folks who who know what
they're talking about which I totally
don't but as a public entity we can make
life so much easier if we just came to a
standard for the data that we're pushing
out and then that we have to bring back
to consume that would that would save a
lot of your tax dollars and to the point
on data ownership our philosophy is if
tax payers have funded it it belongs
ultimately to a taxpayer now does that
mean that an individual person wants to
have all our data no but they should be
able to get it from us in a really
reasonable timeframe and aside from
disciplinary records or legally
confidential stuff it should all be open
because you've already paid for it I
would add that in this this will be a
little bit of the negative side of the
or the opportunity let's call it that I
think that's more appropriate the
Internet of Things right now is really
early days in terms of cyber security
and what we have to know is and you all
know this any device that's connected to
the web is an access point for the bad
guys and I mean Frank you probably have
something to add to this because that's
part of the business I'd welcome that no
no no no I'm just saying if you think
about our early computers there was no
cyber security concerns when we first
connected to the web well now we're
doing hundreds of billions of devices
will connect to the web in the next 10
years
every piece as you know every piece of
electronic that you by including your
electric toothbrush will be connected to
the web not saying that that the bad
guys will get in through our
toothbrushes but we have to be very we
have to be very thoughtful as a
community about what
and I'm just talking to censors I'm not
even talking date of the date everything
said about data I completely agree with
but just even that the protocols and the
security of the devices were putting out
there is a real significant concern and
they're met there are a lot of people
working on that but it is it is by no
means settled science at this point I
guarantee everyone in this room has had
that thing where you're talking to
someone and you think of your phone to
Google and your phone is already telling
you what you were looking for mmm we've
all had that that's just coincidental
right yeah what I would add is that what
we have targeted is all of our
electronic devices will be connected by
2020 and we're talking millions of
devices so we've actually I think it was
in 2012 we bought a company called s
crypt which was a small startup out of
Germany and their focus is cyber
security and so we've this is another
company that again it was developed and
bought in regard to the mobility sector
because we were connecting all the
vehicles and connected cars but now
we're looking at it in exactly the light
you're saying is that all of these
devices will be connected it's not only
the the security purposes but there's
privacy so an amenities so once we
collect all of this data it should be
anonymous data and so one of the areas
that were we're now bringing two cities
is our s script it's a group that looks
at this topic specifically so it's it's
a need because it will happen that's
great so just to follow up on that I
mean Helsinki for instance has Frank be
the app that provides you multimodal
access into and if you use that as a
metaphor and I'll come back to the
shared infrastructure of backhaul and
other using that same example it
provides consumers with low search costs
in the sense that they have this one app
into all the different services however
and it potentially reduces barriers to
entry for new service providers to come
in
however the incumbents whose model is
based on large network effects don't
really like to plug in into a system
like that because there it sort of hurts
their model because you like to use you
over as an app because there are a lot
of drivers on the uber platform and vice
versa there are lot of people wanting to
drive for uber because a lot of people
who have downloaded
virap so this is two-sided network
effect so I was wondering if you had a
comment about that in in in light of
this idea of you know one the shared
infrastructure to multimodal via one app
no certainly so it to be quite frank and
hasn't been easy to get the data I mean
that has clearly been a struggle because
some of the partners were working with
are very eager to expand their services
many of them are smaller then let's say
the larger players but even in regard
with the larger players what we've
realized or what they realize is when
you do have the ability to bring them
more business and it's as more seamless
frictionless process they also see the
benefits we have a couple pilots that
we're doing in Europe one inch stood
guard and we've had good success but
it's been limited again based on the
number of partners because if it doesn't
have all of the modes of transportation
it really doesn't make any sense so it
is a struggle I mean there is a
challenge but it's possible I would say
if all of the the players are
benefitting in some sort from up let's
say a monetary perspective
so let me second Christiane earlier
earlier when he said that you've been
supportive and cooperated with Metro 21
so we thank you for your support but I
thought this panel was really an
excellent composition if you go to
public sector representatives are - from
private companies and one from a public
company right I think is a very
interesting mix so I am wondering
whether the panelists would be willing
to share one or more success stories
we're working with the public entity or
to make a city smarter things worked out
and they would like to share the magics
as a white work and why it's my second
part of the question we need to share
something that did not quite work you
can attract track there any details we
do not want to share that you'll be very
useful as well
success stories and then failure stories
appeal if you will it share because most
of us like to start with success so I do
we do have a success story my last
agency created or a ride
sharing app the story that goes into it
is best told over sankarea and it
involves someone who breaking bad one
off the air and he got bored he went to
drive for a lift and that's the
introduction so so we have success
stories it's a 62 year old man from Iowa
it's like the story gets better but
there is no sangria I think one of the
failures for public entities is we I
don't say we don't know what we don't
know that's really cliche we are
painfully ignorant of what we need to be
asking to adapt our public processes so
public procurements are very they're
cumbersome but they are very
conservative and the intent is to make
sure everyone has the opportunity to get
the money back from the entity this is
great for buying widgets or certain
types of services but when it comes to
you trying to figure out which of the
vendors are willing to come in demo a
Navy shuttle is best how on earth would
I or my team know anything about that
like so we're as smart as we can be but
to get people on to you an evaluation
panel for instance that know something
there all the competition so it becomes
difficult in that public procurement
process to get good technical skills to
help us evaluate so my last entity did
an award for a Navy contract last fall I
and the engineering the prime firm had
an excellent reputation been around
forever but the the vehicle itself was a
firm they've been around you know five
ten years they didn't have that
particular vehicle in production but
they had a good track record and the
public procurement process doesn't let
you ding them for them not having it if
they say they can you have to assume
that they can so we had a prototype
developed delivered in November and the
prototype was like a high school prop
like not even a college prop there were
there were scuff marks on a profit would
not roll so I just want us to think
about that and they had film on the
windows so you couldn't see in but when
you saw in it was a shell and the the
next the embarrassment of it was the
competitor was zipping behind them
autonomously so the next step was to
require a working prototype and they
they sent one
on a flatbed and I would make a joke
about it being like Legos but it was
really like they sent all the components
they just weren't put together and had
we been able to dig more in the industry
we would have had people say oh yeah
those guys but we didn't know so in
carrying the contract with a different
vendor lost two months lost some of the
public money so I'd say that is one of
the failures as our procurement models
of trying to work for us or just they're
not dynamic enough for us not to be
inadvertently stupid please don't quote
me on that but the success story is more
fun than the car it worked I start with
a great success story one that is a
classic example of when when priority is
aligned how much can be done how quickly
so a couple years ago well let me let me
set the stage first having the proper
bandwidth to enable this infrastructure
is very dependent on when you need it to
work the most and when you need it to
work the most is when there's an event
like a playoff game or a security
incident right that's when everybody
gets in their phone and data starts
moving like crazy so we had an
opportunity hope visited Philadelphia a
couple years ago we were contacted by
all of the big four wireless carriers
saying hey we don't have capacity we
need to get small cells in Philadelphia
now we approached the city they
recognized this is a big event it's a
big security event people need wireless
access at least to take their selfies
with the popemobile in the background
which which worked I told you before it
takes usually 24 months at best to get
our small cells deployed in less than
six months right down the Benjamin
Franklin Parkway in Philadelphia we
deployed I think close to a hundred
small cells for each of the carriers and
the event came off perfectly that's a
success story tell you a less than
successful story where we had deployed
small cells in a community on the North
Shore of Long Island have you ever
there that says a lot about regulatory
challenge we went through five years of
regulatory environment got our approvals
deployed per the approvals after we put
the infrastructure up the minutes
probably decided they didn't like it and
they took it down they took it down not
not they asked us to take it down they
took it down that's a disaster disaster
and you know so that that tale continues
to spin but those different
juxtaposition of very willing and eager
community to partner community not so
eager it makes all the difference in the
world the yeah I think not so much a
private industry city example that I
have to share but I think a university
city example that I could share is the
work that that we've done around the
suretrack deployment in the East End
right so that's an instance where we
were using city infrastructure at what
is it 50 different intersections to to
pilot out technology that was developed
here at Carnegie Mellon it meets a
definite business need that the city has
right that you stand is growing area of
the city a lot of traffic congestion
issues and it gave us a platform for
trying out pretty cutting-edge
technology in the public realm so that's
something that I would highlight is you
know a great example of where public
prayer University City collaboration can
really yield some benefits so give two
examples one that's just unfolding as
we're sitting here and then another from
a past life so we just made an
announcement that we continue to expand
our electric vehicle program so one of
the things that we're doing if you think
about as an electric utility it's all
about voltages right we're raising
voltages up and down to move power
across the system which is basically a
transformer a charging station is
basically for an electric vehicle a
transformer you know we're good at
installing maintaining and operating
those type devices so some of the things
that we're doing is we are looking and
partnering you know with some of the
municipalities here as they start
thinking about converting their fleets
that
would put in and on and install we would
hone and operate the charging station so
when you think about that from a
municipality it allows them to stretch
your dollars further to take those
dollars and apply them to vehicle
purchases rather than the charging
infrastructure in a past life public
partnership that we forged with a county
in a city out on the west coast
as an electric utility as you can
imagine with aging infrastructure and
replacing your infrastructure some of
that is below ground some of that
obviously is just you know changing out
aging poles Andry conducting one of the
challenges that we face out there was
that we would go in and we'd set all new
poles and then two or three months later
the county would come out and say we
want to widen the road and move all your
poles that you just put in that have
been two months or likewise we cut the
road and redo it and then they'd come
back and you know want to widen the road
and you know we'd have to take our
electrical conduits and make them deeper
so it was a painstaking process to get
online meant between our two planning
groups to be able to coordinate that
better that took more than a year and a
half to really hone the processes but
once we got it right we had very few
instances where we were making
investments and then having the Conny or
the city coming in and with the decision
to widen a road that they knew about at
the time we were doing it and then we'd
have to move that infrastructure so if
you think about it's all the same
constituents right so at the end of the
day that causes our costs to go up which
are the same constituents the city you
know the city or the municipality is
dealing with already Garden to double
thumbs up sign from Karen but Frank last
word for you really just just a quick
story and this was a project that and we
use it internally as a lessons learned
that was done in Singapore where we
stood up an electric vehicle charging
network with multiple charge point
operators and I think in the in the end
it was 74 different charging point
stations I think it was three or four
different vendors everything went well
it stood up is if it was 2011 it
operated for I think two years everybody
was very happy but the problem was there
was no electric vehicles
[Laughter]
so kind of a success failure story but
we learned a lot and we do use it
internally as the lessons learned and we
hope to take some of those lessons
learns and deploy those in cities so
that's a great story to end on because I
think because I think I hope you learned
a lot and there's beer and pizza coming
up yeah and before the beer and pizza
they're closing thoughts sorry to put
you on a pair care but please join me in
thanking the panelists
[Applause]